there's a lot of places that don't let
me perform simply because I'm black
that doesn't really get to me because
I'm trying to show the world that you
know music is universal a can unite us
all my name is Ryan Lowry and I'm also
known as a fan Pinero and company gross
simply means the black friend I seem
rational musica mexicana panda CRN yo
Norteno mariachi yo soy americano chorus
ohia almaleki Cano since I was little
I've been around Hispanic so I mean it
actually comes naturally it flows out I
grew up in the streets of Compton I
lived in the neighborhood that was
predominantly black and Mexican it's a
wonderful thing to say you know I came
from Compton because they say a lot of
people don't make it out I've traveled
to a lot of places and I'm all over TV
and I can say hey I'm from Compton
a lot of people tell me like hey you're
supposed to be Mexican god just left in
the oven too long I know for a fact that
I am african-american but yeah I do feel
like I live that light I have lived a
run shadow life I've had horses I've had
research goats eggs everything I know
how to saddle up a horse you're not I
make him dance and everything a lot of
people misunderstand and say hey you're
trying to be Mexican too much I'm like
Walt there are American Cowboys there
are people who use boots and just that's
what I was taught what I've been around
but yes like I said in my son like I
said in my son I have the heart and soul
of a Mexican and that I think that that
pretty much is what counts
you